- [Narrator] This in kombucha.
Real kombucha.
That iced tea you buy in
those expensive bottles,
fermented and sweetened?
It's good, but it's not kombucha.
Somewhere along the line the
word was lost in translation.
In Japanese, "cha" means tea,
and this is kombu.
This is the story of the real kombucha.
First the kombu.
Kombu is a type of seaweed
and a staple ingredient
in Japanese cuisine;
and Rishiri Island, off the
northern most tip of Japan,
has become known for the
kombu that grows here.
Zenichi Kosaka is a third
generation fisherman.
(speaking Japanese)
After kombu is harvested and dried,
it can be used to make anything from
soup to salad to garnish,
but for our purposes,
we're gonna make kombucha.
Chiharu Hirakawa is a shop owner
selling kombucha from
locally harvested kombu.
(speaking Japanese)
I have to ask:
do you know about American kombucha?
(speaking Japanese)
Can you guess what it's like?
(buzzer buzzing)
Sorry, nope.
But do you have any words for
those seeking real kombucha?
(speaking Japanese)
(upbeat music)
(ringing tone)